And now it's the old scout master.
Well, listen, if you go up to Canada and you go to all that trouble, you'll want to see
a moose.
That's where we were last week canoeing
Two crews from our troop.
One crew- one of the adults was a very experienced guy and had been up there several times, and
so he was being the advisor for that crew.
I was being the advisor for the other crew
And in my crew I had one adult who had been up there two or three times and I had one adult
who this was his first time up, so he was anxious to see a moose.
So we got together with the other crew at one point during the trip.
They were camped on the same lake but a distance away,
And the adult from that crew told the story of getting up in the morning, going retrieving
the bear bag and having two moose just kind of step right up to him,
You know, just dangerously close.
He did not feel comfortable,
But he got to see these two moose
And the one fellow that was with me was a little jealous, you know, because he'd been looking
for moose and the other guy, you know, they just kind of showed up.
So a couple of days passed and then we heard another story where the guys were sitting
in their campsite. in the other crew, right
Moose comes right up out of the lake, you know, swam across the lake, comes right
up, walks right through the campsite, doesn't seem to pay them any mind or anything like
that.
So they got to see this other moose
And the guy with me is starting to get a little chaffed.
You know why can't I find a moose.
So this is what we figured.
The moose all got together last week, you know, and they said: listen, there's these
two crews coming up and there's one guy in the crew. you know, he's kind of medium,
billed, dark hair, medium height, wears a tan shirt and green pants,
And don't go near that guy,
Don't go near him, you know.
But the other adults with that, with those two crews, you know, just to kind of mess
with that guy, just walk right up next to him.
I mean, at least that's what seemed to have happened.
But I've got to tell you the other fella, his name is Bill,
He got to see his moose before we left and he was a happy guy.
So you know, if you're going to go up to Canada, make sure to keep your eyes
open.
Moose might just scroll right into your campsite,
You never know.
Hey, this is by Cast 133..
Hey, welcome back to the Scott Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green
And, as you heard during the intro there, we just got back from week in Canada.
We had a splendid time.
We brought a little rain up to Ontario.
They were very happy for it.
We brought some rain and cool temperatures
And they were very happy for that.
So you are welcome Ontario. wherever we travel, the rain follows.
So let's look in the mailbag real quick.
We had lots of comments and messages from folks last week while we were away.
Here's a quick selection.
Nick Smith said thanks for Podcast 132..
We're planning a high adventure trip next year, a 50-mile backpacking trip,
and you need a mountains of Utah.
I'm a Scott Master for Troop 1323 in the Great Salt Lake Council
And I have been for four years and I'm loving every minute of the job.
Thanks for putting out the podcast.
I learn and get new insights all the time.
Thanks again.
Thanks, Nick, for being in touch.
Sounds great.
50-miler,
And you know, for anybody who'll listen, put together a high adventure trip.
It doesn't have to be big,
It doesn't have to be special.
You know it can be right there.
It doesn't have to cost a minute of money.
Listen to Podcast 132.
We talk a lot about that.
Mike wrote in to say about a post that we put up for W Ben Hunt,
the author and illustrator.
He said thanks for writing this.
I was always a fan of W Ben Hunt as a kid
And I checked out his books from the library over and over.
There was something about the detailed style of illustrations
that appealed to me and most other boys and girls.
My sisters liked the books too.
If you didn't see the post about Ben Hunt,
go to scoutmastercgcom and take a look at it.
If you're old enough, you might remember one of those books.
And thanks so much, Mike, for getting in touch.
We also did a series of posts last week while I was away
about what a new scout master needs,
And Mike wrote in and said another great entry in this series.
It's great to see a concise summary of how to start.
I'm sure it would have had this a few years ago.
Not sure if this falls under training or resources,
but roundtables can be a great source of information,
While the quality of the content itself can vary widely:
being around other scouts to ask questions,
hear ideas, et cetera, can be very valuable,
especially to a new scout master.
And you are exactly right, Brian,
I should include that in my list of resources-
Roundtables, and, you know, talking to other folks,
It's a big deal and it certainly does help.
Well, in this week's podcast,
we're going to do scout master ship in seven minutes or less,
And we're going to talk a little bit about that series of posts
that we did last week about what a new scout master needs.
So we're going to have our first installment about that
and talk about some of the resources that you can use
to sharpen your skills and improve your work as a scout master,
And we're going to do that in just a moment.
So let's get started, shall we?
Ten, nine, eight, seven,
Six, five, four, three,
Two, one. let's start the fun.
So this is Bob Mazzucchi,
scout executive of the Boy Scouts,
and you're listening to my buddy, Clark Green,
on the scout master podcast
and he is doing a fantastic job:
Scout master ship in seven minutes or less.
Well, you've gone and done it.
Somebody asked you to be a scout master
and now you're a scout master.
So what do you need?
Well, first and foremost, you need to get trained.
We're going to talk about that later on in another podcast.
but training very, very important,
And you also need to be able to supplement that training
by your own reading and study.
You're going to get just so much out of going to a training event.
You're going to need to think and study your way through some things
and then you're also, you know,
going to benefit greatly from experience as you go. as you go by.
Most of the time when scouting goes awry
it's because we adults are ignorant of the program
or we just misunderstand the way something works.
You'll learn how the program works fairly quickly
and spend as many years as you like
perfecting your skills at presenting it.
It's like a game of golf: moments to learn
and a lifetime to master.
You need to know confidently what is and what is not good. scouting
Troops develop their own way of doing things over time
and if you're taking over the scout master position in a troop,
you know- I haven't seen a troop yet, including my own-
They couldn't use some improvement and adjustment
as far as program delivery is involved.
When I say program delivery, I mean:
why are you doing this?
What are you doing?
Why are you involved in scouting?
You know these are all questions
that you have to ask over and over again.
You have to make that program prove itself.
You have to take everything that you do as a troop
and you have to examine it
and you have to say, well, does this really work?
Is this really working
or is this just an old tradition that we have?
I encourage you to study and to learn
and to apply your knowledge,
And I think you need to be courageous enough
to change your mind when you learn something new.
I know that's happened to me several times
and I've had to. you know, let things go
that sometimes we're closely held
and venerated traditions and ways of thinking,
But when you learn something new,
you know it's time to change
And that can be hard for us guys.
It can be hard for us guys
especially if you're, you know, past the age of 45 or 50.
It becomes even more difficult
Now. it's tempting to substitute our own judgment
for 102 years of experience,
and that's what scouting has.
You know it takes a bit of an ego to be a scoutmaster
And we like the way that we think
and we like our own judgment sometimes.
But when we come up against something in the program
that is counter to our own judgment
to our own judgment, we need to ask why,
And 99.99% of the time you're going to go with the program
because it's what makes sense.
And I said you know, 102 years of experience is hard to beat.
So my biggest piece of advice here
is: stick to the program.
You'll never regret it.
Knowledge is power,
And know what resources contain.
Now, knowledge is power, right,
Knowledge is good.
So there are a number of resources out there
that you know. you're not going to commit to memory,
but you're going to know what they contain
And whenever a question arises,
then you're going to run to the resource.
Just remember that little phrase: run to the resource.
Don't substitute your own judgment for it.
Go to the resource, mix your judgment with the resource
and stick with the program.
That's what's the most important thing.
So here's what you'll want to read
cover to cover, maybe with a notebook nearby
ready to take some notes,
maybe with a highlighter in hand
ready to highlight passages.
But it's really important to make sure
that you've gone cover to cover through the following,
And the first one is the Scout Handbook.
Now, get your own copy-
It's the 12th edition now-
And get to know the handbook.
You can teach yourself a great deal
by just reading the handbook,
And it's remarkable
that many adults
involved in scouting
have not actually read the Scout Handbook.
Isn't that something
I mean? it really should
be given a thorough going through
And you should be reasonably familiar
with everything that's in it,
And it will help you immensely
When it comes time for the boys
to teach a given skill,
or something like that.
that's our first point of reference.
We're going to start with the Scout Handbook
and we're going to work with that.
Is it the best single reference
for every outdoor skill
and every single thing in the world?
Well, of course not.
There are books and other resources
that are going to take you deeper into subjects
and everything like that,
but don't substitute your judgment
of what is a thorough treatment of the subject
for what's in the Scout Handbook.
Go with the Scout Handbook,
Stick with the program. that's right there.
The next one that you need to read cover to cover
is the Scout Master Handbook.
Now, this is like a big loose leaf notebook.
It has lots of information and good advice,
and I want you to read it very carefully.
Take a look through it, take these things to heart.
It really means what it says
And it's a great resource.
Now, after I posted this online,
our friend who posts to
scoutmastercgcom occasionally
and we hear during the Scout Master Roundtables,
Walter Underwood, pointed something out.
He said that the Scout Master Handbook is great
but it's kind of thin
when it comes to talking about the patrol method.
So he recommends-
and I join him in recommending-
the Senior Patrol Leaders Handbook.
Have you ever seen that-
It's a little spiral bound affair-
that you can pick up at the Scout Shop
and take a look at that, because that has
a very thorough description
of the patrol method
from a boy's point of view.
and Walter says that
the Scout Master Handbook doesn't really
give you like a job description
for the Scout Master. very well,
but you'll find it in the Senior Patrol Leaders Handbook.
So how about that?
So add that to your list of things
to take a look at: the Senior Patrol Leaders Handbook.
Next, one thing you need to
read carefully
is the Guide to Safe Scouting.
Don't look at this as a set of restrictions.
Okay,
Even though some of the statements in there
are going to tell you what you cannot do,
Take this
as knowledge that empowers you to keep your Scouts safe.
At some point you're going to
find something in the Guide to Safe Scouting
that you don't like.
Don't try to work around it.
Don't look for a way out.
Be loyal to what it says and keep your Scouts
safe. Once again,
don't substitute your own judgment
for what that book has to say.
Next, read
the Guide to Advancement 2011..
Look at the relevant sections
dealing with Scout Advancement.
Read them carefully, Know what they say
and know where to find
the information when questions arise-
And they will-
about the way Advancement is managed
and Boards of Review
and Scout Master Conferences and stuff like that.
The Guide to Advancement 2011
is a great resource.
It will answer 99.9%
of your Advancement questions,
And these questions can sometimes
cause an awful lot of heat in a Scout troop.
So, knowing that stuff
is real important,
The Uniform Insignia
and the Uniform
and Insignia Guide is next.
This answers a lot of those nitpicking
questions that can actually develop into
real problems. Now there are
two basic proper
patch placement
problem people- People placing patches
improperly and people
policing improper patch placement
painfully. How about that
for alliteration? huh,
Don't be either of those people.
You know
boys are going to sew patches on
incorrectly and you might call their attention
to it and say: you know there is
the right place for that.
But you don't want to be doctrinaire and mean
about it. okay,
The Uniform and Insignia Guide
is going to tell you about neckerchiefs.
It's going to tell you about patch placement.
It's going to tell you about when
you have to wear the uniform. Hey,
it's a great resource and if it's not
in there, it doesn't matter.
You know,
there are
sometimes people who take
some of the uniform rules of the military
and they try to apply them to scouts
and they get all upset about it.
Uniform and Insignia Guide
is going to solve those problems
and calm the waters a little bit.
Next,
the AIDS to Scout Mastership
by Baden Powell.
This is kind of a pamphlet.
I think it's about 40 pages long
and I would read it.
Now you're going to have to read
an English military man's
description of scouting and in that
you're going to find some anachronisms.
but you're going to read through that
and you're going to get a very good sense
from the founder
of a succinct description
of the movement that he founded.
Scouting's essential concept
will ring true a century later
and it's well worth your time
to get a copy of AIDS to Scout Mastership
and to read it through,
and it's widely available online.
It's very easy to find in a PDF file
online.
I also have a Scout Masters Bookshelf
that you can reference through
a link on the post.
that contains this podcast
at scoutmastercgcom.
and let's talk about other sources
of information:
The official Boy Scouts of America
publication
or an official BSA
online resource.
it's not an authoritative source of information
and that includes
my podcast and that includes
scoutmastercgcom.
If what I say or write is not consistent
with the policies and practices
of Boy Scouts of America, I'm wrong.
It's very simple.
I think it's important to test
every source of information
through official resources
before you act on them,
and I've got a lot of online resources
over at scoutmastercgcom
that you want to take a look at.
but once again, you want to test them
against those official
things like the Scout Handbook,
like the Scout Masters Handbook,
the Uniform Insignia Guide,
the Guide to Advancement
and the Guide to Safe Scouting.
There's lots of well-intentioned advice out there
that may be outdated
and it's fairly easy nowadays
with the web
and with the easy availability
of all these resources,
to check them out
and to make sure you've got it straight.
I hope that helps you
if you're a new scoutmaster
or an old scoutmaster,
check those resources out
and be ready to use them
to answer any questions
or to clarify anything in your mind.
and remember, run to those resources
when questions arise.
then you'll have it right.
you'll be sticking with the program.
don't substitute your own judgment
for 102 years of experience.
learn what scouting is
and how to properly deliver to program
and you will be a successful scoutman.
Well, thanks so much for listening.
Let me tell you how to keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can subscribe to this podcast,
the Scoutmaster podcast, on iTunes
when you do, if you have the time,
leave a comment or review a rating.
it sure makes a difference
and I'll see you next time.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about that
at Stitchercom.
How about sending a shout out that'll be broadcast
right here on the podcast?
Yeah, that's right, you can do it.
go to scoutmastercgcom,
look for the shout out link
and it will give you instructions on exactly how to do that.
You can experience all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right. you can follow
your blog on Facebook,
Tweet scoutmastercg on Twitter
and for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle.
search for scoutmastercg on Google Plus
and remember
you can always email me.
Hey, that's simple.
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
that's scoutmastercg
I need to tell you the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
It's just me,
That's right, talking into a microphone
and I'm trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
So before we leave you,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert, good luck to you
and good hunting,
Sir, until next time.